What I want to focus on in this video is what is Khan's Academy now and where do I see it in the future ...
..what I hope to develop. So ... most of you are probably already familiar with the video list / library
which is available at the Khan Academy. There are 1400 videos that deal with everything from general mathematics, biology, chemistry ...
..., there's also a section about the economy ... but I see it grow great outside the videos, and I've already started working on software.
This here is basically the "Knowledge Map" of the Khan Academy. And you can get to her at khan exercises.appspot.com. You just need a Google ID and you can sign in.
It's free and hopefully it will be forever. And when you click on the small button "Knowledge Maps" you will see something like this for yourself. It will show you basically the current software curriculum.
Now I want to be very precise: Videos (and 1400) are more extensive than the software. Software Now - Because it is frankly more work intensive and I was the only worker or I should rather say "Sal-intensive" than video -
now there are only about 70 software modules. And this includes everything from general mathematics through Algebra 2. But the idea here is to get everyone started on the basic rung that is enough. This module here is 1 + 1 = 2
or 2 + 3 = 5, and as they get up to ten in lanes in the right row, it starts to move at their pace on more advanced topics.
You know we have an equation system here. Multiplying expressions and so on and so on. And just get to the idea of ​​what this actually looks like
again, you can click on the module and start working on it. But this screenshot of one of the modules. This is a screenshot of the multiplication of decimal places and the paradigm I think this software lists
although it may look very bright - we transform into what we classically teach and study.
So the traditional model is that we have a lesson, you - you have a lesson where you normally are when everyone in the room is together at a certain time. And then there is some practice as part of a homework ... home ... yourself and when you get stuck
you are on your own and you can hardly help. The book might mention what's right, but you're not able to find out why it's a good or bad solution.
And then you have some form of evaluation. Some types of quizzes, you may reach 80% or 90% of the quiz and then mark B or A, but then move to the next topic.
And thanks to this structure, and it really is not the fault of the individual, but rather the product of the system ... everyone needs to learn at their own pace. An hour where one-to-30 people are at their own pace, no matter if half the class is lost or half the class bored. This is what everyone has of it, no matter how good a teacher is
... you have to adapt to everyone. So some percentage will be lost and some percentage bored and it doesn't matter if you get 10% or 20% wrong
or 30% wrong, because if you thrive it moves to the next topic. And anyone familiar with math or science knows that if you know the core of your weakness ... when there are 10% of the problems you don't know how to do ...
.... later on when you move to a more advanced theme - this will be a crucial part of your foundation and it will basically be impossible to move to a higher level.
So this is a traditional model.
What this software defends, or maybe what I advocate, is a model where everything happens at the same time in a very large environment.
So we start with the instructions. This is a crucial point in the lesson, but this time we're doing it with this framework, we'll have instructions from the video.
So let's say you see the decimal multiplier module for the first time in your life, so on your "Knowledge Map" you are roughly 10 in the right row on the fourth level of multiplication ...
... so now it is now showing that you are working on multiplying decimal places and it will increase because you see it for the first time.
You have no idea how to do it. You can click "watch video" and this window will pop up and you can watch a video about multiplying decimal places
from khan academy.org; you will be redirected right into it. And after you see it, you can start to practice problems, and once again the paradigm is very different.
If you do not know this crucial problem, you can click on "tip" and this will show you your problem step by step. So when that person comes to see the problem for the first time, he sees the problem ...
... and all this understanding started after they clicked on "tip" and I urge you to try it on khan exercises.appspot.com.
Now that you start being good, it doesn't move you if you have 90% or 80% and you are labeled as B + Students or A Students, this says "I want you to continue solving the problems with decimal digits ..."
"... and I / software / will still generate multiplication problems for you, even if it costs 1000 problems before you get to the top ten in the line.
So the paradigm or the idea of ​​what I'm trying to defend here is not to keep moving until you are sure of your complete concept knowledge. And right here on the strip you can try to correct your problems ...
... the stars won't show until you reach at least 10 in the line and when that happens it says "Hi, you really know how to do it, we think we could move on to the next topic."